so I'm on tour you saw me or they're
right here they're in ears we call them
in ears but you can decorate them and I
go gold sparkly 7s um but you have
photos on yours I didn't know you could
do photos yeah you can put photos no one
told me this yeah you put photos of your
kids photos of anyone those are mine
Edward that that's my that's my baby
like that's my thing yeah that's Twi
that's Edward Colin on my in
ear
yes ni purple lavender I like it yeah
he's my Guiding Light tour you know have
to have my lucky charm uh yeah love him
what's on your in ears now my in ear now
for this guts tour I'm I'm going to get
a new face every tour so taking
suggestions for the next one maybe I'll
put you on my next one aim for like
something random like Betty White like
something random right yeah but this
year is makes you happy totally oh it's
Kim katrol it's Kim
Kon I love that it's Kim kol from from
Sex in the City Samantha from Sex in the
City she's my favorite and she's like
drinking a little martini and I thought
it was why not why not you know what
that says celebrate every time you put
your ears in I like it I think I did
know you could do photos do you have Rue
do you have Rue on yours oh okay her dog
I was like maybe I have seen photos I
know I need to be cooler I'm going to
aim
[Music]
[Applause]
higher thank you guys yall have a great
night I'm going
home